WE'LL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON, LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. BEFORE WE HEAR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE BILLS, LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ARCHULETA HERE. GROVE. ALVARADO.
GILL, PRESENT. MIN LA UMBERG
HERE. WE'VE GOT A QUORUM, SIR.
OKAY. MADAM SECRETARY NOTES THAT
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. AND AS I
MENTIONED, WE HAVE SIX BILLS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, SO, MADAM
SECRETARY, LET'S GET A MOTION.
FIRST MOTION MOVED. TOM UMBERG,
HIS MOTION. SO, LET'S GO AHEAD.
AND, MADAM SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. YES SIR, THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ARCHULETA HERE. YES,
YES, AYE. GROVE. ALVARADO GILL.
AYE. ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
MENGIBAR UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE SHALL WE HOLD THAT OPEN,
SIR? OKAY. WHAT DID WE GET?
THREE. AYE. AND WE'LL HOLD THAT,
ON CALL. THANK YOU. OKAY. NEXT
ITEM WE HAVE, I DON'T SEE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. TO CAN WE GIVE
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER A CALL,
PLEASE?
THE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS WILL GO ON
RECESS FOR JUST A FEW MINUTES.
AND.
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY
AND VETERANS AFFAIRS WILL COME
TO ORDER, AND WE WILL OPEN UP.
AND WE WILL HAVE OUR FIRST
PRESENTER ON AB 1793. WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO. AND YOU CAN
PRESENT YOUR BILL. GOOD
AFTERNOON. AND, THANK YOU,
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS BILL, AB 1793. WE ENSURE
THAT DEPENDANCE ON ACTIVE DUTY
MILITARY MEMBERS DEPLOYED
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA, BUT
MAINTAINING CALIFORNIA RESIDENCY
WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR CALTRAIN
AND THE MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP
PROGRAM. MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS WHO ARE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS MAY SOMETIMES RECEIVE
GOVERNMENT ORDERS REQUIRING THEM
TO RELOCATE OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
FOR A STANDARD PERIOD, AND THEIR
FAMILIES OFTEN ACCOMPANY THEM
SINCE THEIR PARENTS ARE STILL
RESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA. THE
STUDENT QUALIFY FOR AN IN-STATE
TUITION RATE AT OUR COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITIES. HOWEVER, UNDER
CURRENT LAW, STUDENTS ARE
INELIGIBLE FOR COVERAGE OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
IF THEY TEMPORARILY RESIDE OUT
OF STATE DUE TO THE DEPLOYMENT,
AB 1793 WOULD ONLY APPLY TO A
VERY SPECIFIC GROUP OF ACTIVE
DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS, SO THIS
BILL DOES NOT APPROPRIATE ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR THE CURRENT
PROGRAM IS SIMPLY ALLOW
DEPENDENTS OF ACTIVE DUTY
CALIFORNIA MILITARY MEMBERS TO
ACCESS THE RENT. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR, IS THERE ANY
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
YOUR BILL? OKAY, I SEE NONE.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION OF YOUR
BILL, AND I SEE ONE, NONE. OKAY,
LET'S GO AHEAD AND, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? NOPE, MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY AND THAT WAS, WE DO HAVE
SOMEONE Þ PUBLIC, RICHARD MAHER
FROM AMERICA FIRST POLICY AND
SUPPORT. OKAY. APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
AND I HAVE A MOTION FROM,
SENATOR MARIE ALVARADO. GIL. SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND PROCEED.
MADAM SECRETARY, AB 1793 DO
PASS. BUT FIRST WE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ARCHULETA I,
ARCHULETA I, GROFF ALVARADO, GIL
I ALVARADO, GIL I, AND MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR I BURKE SIR, THAT DOES
PASS. WHAT DO YOU WANT? TO HOLD
IT OPEN AND WE HAVE THREE. WE'LL
HOLD THAT BILL OPEN, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU. I THINK IT'S
A GREAT BILL, AND I THANK YOU
FOR PRESENTING IT. I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT, SENATOR. THANK
YOU. ADD ON TO CONSENT. YEAH FOR
SENATOR. SENATOR MENGIBAR, DO
YOU WANT TO ADD ON TO CONSENT?
YES. OKAY. GOOD GO AHEAD AND
CALL IT, THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
GROVE MENGIBAR MENGIBAR I DO WE
WANT TO STILL HOLD THAT OPEN,
SIR. YOU I'LL HOLD IT OPEN. ONE
MORE. ONE FOR GROWTH. YES. YEAH
OKAY. AND, ANY WORD ON OUR NEXT
PRESENTER, CHABOT HEARST. YOU'VE
BEEN UNDERWAY. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
YEAH NO, NO. WE'RE GOING TO GO
ON RECESS FOR NEXT FIVE, TEN
MINUTES UNTIL WE GET THE AUTHOR
DOWN. THANK YOU. SO.
THE MEETING ON THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS WILL WILL
REOPEN, AND, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHABOT, WELCOME. AND I
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 1994. SO
YOU ARE WELCOME TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, GOOD AFTERNOON. I
AM THANKFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB 1994. THIS IS A
COMMITTEE BILL THAT WILL
ESTABLISH IN STATUTE, IN STATE
STATUTE, THE POSITION OF DEPUTY
SECRETARY, SECRETARY OF MINORITY
AND UNDERREPRESENTED VETERAN
AFFAIRS AT CALVERT, THERE IS AN
INCREASING UNDERSTANDING AND
RECOGNITION THAT VETERANS OF THE
US ARMED FORCES, WHO COME FROM
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR OR
UNREPRESENTED GROUPS, FACE
STRUCTURAL INEQUALITIES THAT ARE
NOT MITIGATED BY THEIR MILITARY
SERVICE. MINORITY VETERANS ARE
LESS LIKELY TO RECEIVE BENEFITS
AND OFTEN LIVE IN AREAS WHERE
THERE ARE SERVICE GAPS. NATIVE
AMERICAN VETERANS, IN
PARTICULAR, WHO'S REPRESENTATION
IN THE ARMED FORCES IS DOUBLE
THEIR PROPORTION OF THE GENERAL
POPULATION ARE LESS LIKELY TO
RECEIVE BENEFITS THAT THEY WERE
ENTITLED TO, OR COULD HAVE
ESTABLISHED ELIGIBILITY FOR. THE
POSITION OF DEPUTY SECRETARY OF
MINORITY AND UNDERREPRESENTED
VETERAN AFFAIRS WAS CREATED
ADMINISTRATIVELY, AND THE
SECRETARY LACKED DIRECT STAFF
UNTIL THE BUDGET OF 2019 2020,
WHEN THE ASSEMBLY ADVOCATED FOR
THE ADDITION OF THREE POSITIONS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT REPORTING
TO THE DEPUTY. THE BILL MAKES.
THE BILL IS IMPORTANT TO MAKE
PERMANENT THE POSITION OF DEPUTY
SECRETARY OF MINORITY AND
UNDERREPRESENTED VETERAN AFFAIRS
, AND TO SIGNAL THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO UNDERREPRESENTED
VETERANS AND TO ENSURE THEIR
CONTINUED REPRESENTATION IN
CALVERT. THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION, NOW,
DO YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT? NO, I SEE NONE. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? THÀNH I
SEE NONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SHE SAID NO, BILL. OH,
AND I HAVE, SENATOR MANCHIVADU
MOVE THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. SO,
MADAM SECRETARY, CALL THE ROLE
AB 1994. DO PASS. BUT FIRST WE
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ARCHULETA I ARCHULETA I GROVE
ALVARADO GIL MENJIVAR. MENJIVAR
I UMBERG. SIR, WE NEED TO LEAVE
THAT. OKAY, WE'LL HOLD THAT BILL
. THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
PRESENTING THAT. THANK YOU. I
VOTED ON EVERYTHING YOU DID.
OKAY, GREAT. YEAH IS. NOW SHE
GOT THEM ALL. SHE'S ON ALL OF
THEM, GROVE AND UMBERG ARE NOT
ON ANY OF THEM. OKAY OH, NO,
BURGES, ON THE CONSENT. SO YEAH.
OKAY SO, YEAH, IT'S ON CALL.
YEAH. IT'S OPEN. STILL OKAY,
SENATOR, LET'S LET'S OPEN THE,
ROLL ONCE AGAIN FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LET'S
SEE. WHAT DO WE GOT? HE GOT
1793. HOW ABOUT 1793? AB 1793.
DO PASS, BUT FIRST REFERRED
PREPARATIONS. GROVE UMBERG Ã
UMBERG I SO THAT ONE DOES PASS
OUT. BUT WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR GROVE. YEAH, WE'LL
WAIT FOR SENATOR GROVE. BUT,
1994. YES. YEP AND THEN WE HAVE,
THIS, SENATE BILL, ASSEMBLY
BILL, 1994, ASSEMBLY BILL, 1994
DO PASS BUT REFER. FIRST, WE
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS GROVE,
ALVARADO, GIL UMBERG UMBERG I
THAT BILL PASSES. HOLD THAT ONE
OPEN. OKAY. YOU'RE GOOD. YOU'RE
ON. OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ALL RIGHT. SO NOW. YOU
MIKE IS STILL ON. SO WE'RE GOING
TO GO, WE'LL GO ON RECESS FOR
JUST A FEW MINUTES.
SENATE COMMITTEE ON MILITARY AND
VETERANS AFFAIRS WILL REOPEN.
AND, WE WILL OPEN THE ROLL ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY I
WILL WAIT UNTIL SHE'S READY.
SORRY. THAT'S OKAY. NO RUSH.
YEAH. THEY GAVE US ALL THIS
TECHNOLOGY, AND YOU HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO OPERATE IT. OKAY, VETS
COMMITTEE, MILITARY AND VETERANS
AFFAIRS. I'M THERE. READY? YES
OKAY, MADAM SECRETARY, CALL THE
ROLL. AND WE'RE. THIS IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. OKAY. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. GROVE Ã
GROVE. AYE. THERE'S IT'S FIVE
ZERO PASSES OUT, FIVE ZERO. OKAY
AND THEN, LET'S, GIVE THE
SENATOR A CHANCE TO VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY BILL 1793, AB 1793 DO
PASS. BUT FIRST, WE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS GROVE. GROVE I
THAT'S FIVE ZERO PASSES OUT.
OKAY. AND THAT'S FIVE ZERO. AND,
I THINK WE'LL THAT'LL THAT'LL DO
IT. ONE MORE AB 1994 AB 1994
ZERO. OKAY, AN ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT, 1994, MADAM SECRETARY
CALLED THE ROLL AB 1994 DO PASS.
BUT FIRST REREFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS. GROVE. GROVE. I
ALVARADO GILL. SO THAT'S FOUR
DOES PASS OUT. OKAY. THAT'S
FOUR. WE'LL WAIT FOR HER. I
DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S GOING TO
COME BACK OR NOT. NO, SHE SAID
SHE WAS COMING BACK. OKAY DO YOU
KNOW WHERE ENERGY IS? SO WE WILL
GO ON RECESS.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S OPEN UP THE
ROLES AND BEGIN, OPEN UP FOR THE
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEE ON ON,
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS.
AND WE HAVE ONE VOTE, ONE VOTE,
ONE VOTE. SENATOR MARIE
ALVARADO. GUILT, I THINK, DID
YOU DO YOU DID YOU VOTE FOR
CONSENT? SHE DID. SHE JUST NEEDS
ONE BILL, SIR. SO ONE BILL,
WHICH ONE WAS 1793, 1994? 1793?
YOU DID THAT ONE, 1790. BILL AB
1994, MADAM SECRETARY READ AB
1994 DO PASS. BUT FIRST WE
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS.
ALVARADO GIL A ALVARADO GIL I
PASSES OUT FIVE ZERO. OKAY.
THAT'S IT. AND BEFORE YOU GO.
YES. AND WHILE WE'RE STILL
ROLLING AND ON THE RECORD, I'D
LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE TODAY AND OUR PATIENCE AND
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY NOW, TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR BEING HERE. BUT I
WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
CONGRATULATE CINDY BALDWIN, WHO
SERVED THE STATE SENATE FOR OVER
24 YEARS. AND DURING THAT TIME,
SHE MADE, MADE AND MAINTAINED
NUMEROUS CONNECTIONS WITH THE
MILITARY AND VETERANS COMMUNITY
TO HELP BETTER THE LIVES OF
THOSE HERE IN CALIFORNIA. SHE
LOVES OUR VETERANS AND ON TOP OF
THAT, HER OFFICIAL DUTIES IN HER
FREE TIME, WHICH SHE CALLS HER
OFFICIAL DUTIES. CINDY IS AN
ADVOCATE FOR VETERANS AND FOSTER
CHILDREN. SHE IS A VETERAN
TREATMENT COURT MENTOR FOR
HELPING VETERANS AND THOSE
INVOLVED WITH VETERANS AND THEIR
FAMILIES, WITH THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM TO GO THROUGH A PROCESS
TO CONNECT WITH NECESSARY
SERVICES TO BETTER THEIR LIVES
AND REDUCE, MEN AND WOMEN FROM
GOING BACK INTO PRISON. MEN AND
WOMEN GOING BACK AND HAVING
PROBLEMS. IT'S SOMETHING VERY
IMPORTANT TO HER. SO CINDY IS
ALSO A COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATE HELPING CHILDREN IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. SHE IS A MOTHER OF TWO,
A GRANDMOTHER OF ONE, WITH
ANOTHER LITTLE MUSTANG ON THE
WAY. AND THAT'S WHAT I CALL MY
GRANDCHILDREN MUSTANGS. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO WISH HER FAREWELL
AND HOPE THAT SHE WILL FIND ALL
THE JOY, LOVE AND HAPPINESS AND
PEACE THAT SHE DESERVES AND
ALWAYS UPWARD AND ONWARD. AND I
KNOW THAT SHE'S VERY PROUD OF
WORKING WITH ALL OF US ON THE
COMMITTEE, BUT I KNOW SHE IS SO
PROUD OF HER DAUGHTER, WHO'S A
DOCTOR IN LOS ANGELES, AND I'VE
BEEN FOLLOWING HER CAREER FOR A
GOOD NUMBER OF YEARS. BUT ON
THAT NOTE, I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
HER AND PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGE HER
SERVICE. THANK YOU SIR. IT'S
BEEN AN HONOR. THANK YOU. IF WE
HAD ANOTHER 20 MINUTES, I'D KEEP
READING. I KNOW, BUT AGAIN, SO
ON THAT NOTE, THE SENATE
MILITARY AND VETERANS COMMITTEE
WILL BE ADJOURNED. THANK YOU
EVERYONE. THANK YOU SIR.